so um you know the
the problem is i mean the scale of these
things now are huge and so of course
they're very expensive
and this gets back to
you know the issue we talked about right
at the beginning of this as
um what is the value you know what what
value does society place on these things
that um are as soma said not necessary
for survival
but they are you know intrinsic to our
need
to understand and our curiosity and uh
um you know that's something we as a
society have to
evaluate that's an interesting question
how much money do you know how much
money
has been dumped into the large hadron
collider to date or into cern
and who who pays for all that so i mean
i think the
the the construction of the large
hydrant collider was
i think they say about 10 billion
dollars
to you know get it to the point of
finding the higgs boson
um it's a consortium so cern which is
the
consortium of uh countries
was actually uh an outgrowth of unesco
so it was
created shortly after uh the end of
world war ii
and it was a consortium of european
countries that
the idea was to unite these countries
who
often who had been very recently
enemies into the peaceful pursuit of
science
the idea is that science um could be
this unifying
this unifying endeavor that you know
there's a truth to science
that uh would transcend political
differences
and opinions and things like that and
uh and so uh there are these founding
you know members of cern and they
each contribute money based on their
size
and so that's where a lot of the money
comes from and then there are
other affiliate countries and
institutions
that contribute money for the privilege
to be able to work on these experiments
because
you know essentially if you want to uh
if you want to be at the forefront of
understanding particle physics
you need to be you know participating at
cern
and so other countries like the us the
us is a huge
contributor are they really yeah i was
asking i was going to ask you how much
of this money does the us
how much input does the us have like
financially into this you know i'm not
sure how much but it's
i mean it's probably at least
i don't know i mean again i'm not sure
i'd say
order a magnitude of 200 million or
something like that so it's not it's not
it's not inconsiderable um and so what
happens is
it usually it can come from uh
it can come from the u.s government but
often
also from universities so universities
that want to participate they want to
send their
their students there then they
contribute
and they get affiliated with one of the
experiments so whether you know whether
it's atlas or cms
or lacb um
they um contribute a certain amount of
uh money you know for their students to
go
and to work there and so that's what you
saw in the film
um is that um
monica the graduate student monica
she was formally i think at that point
she changed she was at university of
pennsylvania that she was at university
of chicago she was formerly university
of chicago student
she was living at cern working at cern
full time but
you know it was the university of
chicago collaboration that was working
on
atlas and
they you know contribute a certain
amount of money to do that and they
build things they work on it
so they work on the detectors so cern
itself
is really i think i i believe really
supported by
the um members you know so that's the
ring
you know that's permanent staff you know
um
uh i think there's 1500 or so people
that are permanent there
that are part of cern the experiments
are really they're they're independent
things
they are and they're supported by
the institutions that participate in it
so all the universities that work on
atlas or
alice or lacb or cms
they are independent organizations
groups of universities the companies out
there yeah we want to work on this
together
and we're going to have uh we're going
to put this much money into the
experiments
so uh the funding for the experiments is
a little different from the funding
of the ring that they make they'll
maintain
the ring the interesting thing to me
about all this
i think the most interesting thing to me
is that you know there's so much that
goes into
this massive massive undertaking
of the lhc and all the experiments that
go on
and it's it's a very difficult
thing for a normal everyday civilian to
wrap their mind around right
um you know normally if someone explains
this to somebody who's never heard about
it you say well what's the point
what's the goal what's the goal of all
this but
what i've realized is that
no matter what the goal is the coolest
thing is that all the things that you
can discover
on the way to that goal like for example
the world wide web
like all the different innovations that
come along
in the process of trying to reach some
peak you know what i mean or some summit
of some like some
big discovery some aha discovery
is that the the the interesting things
that are innovated or discovered or
learned about on the you know during the
process
yeah all right well i think that is
exactly the point you know and again it
relates to this question we brought up
right at the head that that sabas
encapsulates in other people is that um
um you know
the people that do this for the most
part don't do it because they want to
uh make a better mousetrap you know
they're doing it because we want to
understand but the offshoot of that is
um unpredictable and uh immeasurable
and it has resulted in so many other
things
um as i say already i mean from the lhc
i mean the advances that we've gotten in
understanding you know um how to work
with super
cool temperature things materials
sciences
uh optics things um magnetic
magnetic phenomena information
processing
um you know the web um
[Music]
yeah i mean you know even even just the
the simplest level of information i
remember
um a number of years ago um
you know we obviously are having an
information explode we have we're living
in an age of information explosion
and um my uh
a cousin of mine was working in the
field of
bioinformation and you know in
particular dealing with all the genetic
sequencing
and our understanding of genes and you
know
uh this used to be it used to be very
hard and
expensive um but it was changing where
now the cost of um you know sequencing
dna
was getting you know less and less and
easier and easier
and suddenly people in biology were
being
you know faced with an enormous amount
of data
and they didn't know you know how do you
deal with this and so they decided they
need to see
seek out the advice of the people that
deal with the most data of
all and it's the people it served and so
they went to them and talked to them and
so
one of the things that that you know was
interesting he said at that
time is that at cern the amount of data
created at the lhc you know the
trillions and trillions of collisions
every second
there's it's impossible for us to
uh imagine we can't we can't deal with
it okay it's happening too quick for our
computers we can't
possibly store it all and so the first
stage
in after the collision is that it goes
to an analysis it's called the trigger
and it immediately uh throws away
a huge amount of data which is uh things
that they
already know about and are not
interesting and so
it filters out at the very first stage a
lot of uninteresting things
that were not needed there's a lot of
junk a lot of things that aren't
interesting
and um because they just can't even deal
with anything else so
this is a very you know and of course
it's a very tricky thing because you're
throwing away data
and but there's no alternative we just
couldn't deal with it and
what my cousin had said is at that point
he said biology wasn't at that
uh point where they could imagine
throwing away data but they were going
to have to get to that point you know
because there was
and so how to do that intelligently is
something again
it's not something you would even expect
necessarily would uh be a result of the
you know physics but it's part of it and
um
it's one of the things that has been an
outgrowth of of
this you know you're pushing the
frontiers
of understanding in science and
technology
and that does eventually have
uh you know it can have a certain
unexpected benefit